greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
and today we're going to talk about how
to increase YouTube subscribers so with
YouTube it's all about subscribers the
number of subscribers you have on
YouTube it's just one of the key metrics
to measure success so gaining more
subscribers can help you achieve more
view counts on your YouTube videos so
it's all about how to get subscribers
and today we're going to talk about how
to get more subscribers and before we
begin let's just show you what we did it
simply learned so if we look at the past
365 days on our YouTube channel you can
see we started here back in if we look
back at March 9 2000 18 we had 208 and
you can see just over the course of the
year it kept creeping up creeping up
creeping up and creeping up we've gained
you know a significant number of
subscribers over the last year and
what's our secret well it's posting
videos so you can see we've posted a
number of videos over the course of the
year and then our subscribers have gone
basically a hundred and sixty five
percent over the last year so you can
see it's part of it is about posting
videos because when you post videos you
have people who can watch those videos
we have people watch those videos you
can have engagement and then when you
have engagement you have shares and
people who like it and then other people
who see it so it's kind of a halo effect
so to speak so we're getting subscribers
takes a lot more than just posting
videos and today we're gonna talk about
some tips to help you increase the
subscriptions so let's start out with
some of those tips we're gonna start
with creating engagement and informative
content so engaging informative content
that's where we're gonna start talking
today about how to increase
subscriptions then we're going to talk
about publishing videos frequently so if
it's simply learn you can see the past
365 days we were consistent in
publishing videos consistently
throughout the month in the weeks so
another tip we're going to talk about is
how to optimize your YouTube videos so
there's a lot that goes into
optimization
but this is a key key tip to pay
attention to because when you comes to
posting publishing videos on YouTube you
need to align certain things like
keywords and content and metadata so
optimize our videos we're going to talk
a lot about that then we're going to
talk about optimizing the YouTube
channel so there's some tips and tricks
here you want to do to optimize your
YouTube channel producing high quality
videos we're gonna talk about fat adding
a subscriber watermark to your videos
okay that's another tip we're gonna
mention today engage with our audience
today that's what we want to do we want
to engage with our audience that's a
really key tip we're saving the best for
last
promote your videos in different
platforms so all of these tips we're
gonna talk about today so let's get
started and talk about create engaging
informative content so that's the first
place we want to start ok so create
engaging informative content so if we
want to gain more subscribers on our
channel we have to create highly
engaging and informative content why
because not our audience is not going to
pay attention and they're not gonna
watch the video and then then the
engagements not gonna be high and
they're not gonna share the video and
they're not gonna tell their friends or
like it and so this is where it all
starts you have to be able to plan your
content and not only planning your
content but you got to create it so it's
engaging and informative so how do you
do that well let's talk about that so
the first thing is you have to know your
audience
when you create a video who you're
creating the video for I mean that's
where it all starts
so when you're creating your content
you're creating your content for your
audience you're not creating it for the
entire world now we know on YouTube
there's a lot of cute videos about
kittens and jokes and you know people
playing games and you know everybody
likes positive things on YouTube but you
know when we're talking about a specific
topic you know we really have to hone in
on a target audience and so if you know
who your audience is then you can really
hone in on your content okay so that's
the first thing ask yourself who is your
audience and then build your content
around that specific audience don't
build it just for the mass general
population because it's not
gonna be engaging and informative so
that's the first place to start then you
want to engage that audience with
relevant content if you know your
audience and depending on the topic you
want to make sure that whatever the
topic is the content matches the topic
don't they're off course if you veer off
course you're not going to engage your
viewers your viewers are coming to watch
the video for specific reason the reason
is the topic okay so if they're your
target audience and they want to watch
the video that's a specific topic then
the content has to align so plan your
video script so if you know who your
audience is and you know you want to
engage them with relevant content go
ahead and plan the script out so what I
normally do is you know have an outline
and then once I have the outline then I
go ahead and create my slides if I will
or my topics points I want to talk about
and then I write out those points I want
to make sure I get all my points in and
that's what you should be doing you want
to plan it ahead of time so that you can
get all your relevant points across
that's what makes a video informative
can you want to ensure to give maximum
information to your audience so the key
here is maximum information so you don't
want to overload the audience but then
again you want to cut out information so
you want to make sure that when you're
planning your script and you're writing
the outline that you're making sure you
include all your points that you want to
get across once you include those points
then go ahead and you know write your
script and make sure all the information
for all those points are in the script
that's how you're going to ensure you
give maximum information but you don't
want to overdo it so if you feel like
it's too much information it probably is
too much information back off a little
use the information to create another
video so it's all about knowing your
audience so all of these points play
against one another so be clear and use
more examples in your content just like
we're doing here okay just like at the
beginning of this session I showed you
an example is simply learn subscribers
over the past 365 days and so that's
what we want to do we want to be clear
but use examples to punctuate the
content or the point we're trying to get
across so we want to include sources
from high-quality sites so if you're
going to use exam
holls make sure they're from relevant
high-quality sites when I make high
quality meaning does your audience know
who that source is or that site if it's
really specific and your audience may
not know then it's probably not high
quality so just keep that in mind always
play to your audience so you want to
start your video with an interesting
hook so again I go back to this example
if you're still watching this then the
hook worked we showed you our
subscriptions we showed you how we grew
over the course of a year you could see
our growth and part of it was posting a
lot of videos with relevant and
informative content and so you see how
we did it so you're paying attention you
want to know how to do it and so part of
what we did is exactly what I'm telling
you now we know who our audience is we
plan on our scripts we use good examples
and we start our videos with interesting
hooks now when we do our videos we also
create original content so that goes
back to planning your script okay you
always want to you know come across as
original and informative when you do
that you're going to be engaging but if
you're leveraging somebody else's
content then the engaging part may not
resonate because it's not your content
to begin with so always always always
use original content okay so keep the
content flow organized so again that
goes back to an outline you know feel
free to change up the outline so the
flow makes sense
add visuals to your content and make it
appealing always include images to me if
you can use images in your videos and
play off the video or the images then
it's just gonna flow and make it a
little bit more engaging and appealing
meaning the content so visuals help
guide and aid in the point you're trying
to make so don't make it so text heavy
you know accentuate it balance it with
some images use simple language and
crisp sentences meaning don't choose
your again don't come across and talk
above your audience you always want to
talk to your audience and talk in a
language that they're gonna understand
so it goes back to point one if you know
who your audience is you're talking to
them as if they're right in front of you
and not your above them or they're below
you you want to talk at them so at
cards and screens and pattern interrupts
to engage your audience and so YouTube
cards or just interactive panels that
slide in and out when a video is playing
so it encourages interaction by the
viewer okay so you can add up to five
cards which include images text or
clickable links so feel free to play
around with some of these features that
YouTube has to offer to make your
content more engaging so tip 2 publish
videos frequently so creating and
uploading videos consistently will help
you increase your YouTube subscribers so
suppose you haven't published videos
from more than say a month or two months
it's likely that that audience not gonna
subscribe to your channel so think about
YouTube videos as a popular TV program
that comes on once a week when a new
episode comes on based on the regular
schedule it's consistently and that
consistency is what helps your users
stay engaged so for example if I go back
to our YouTube channel you know what
helped us gain subscribers was our
consistency in publishing videos you
could see we were consistent publishing
a couple of videos a week every couple
of weeks and so this helps users stay
engaged they know when the video is
coming out they know that simply learn
is good for two three four videos a
month and the great thing about
publishing videos is that when somebody
does subscribe to your channel they're
gonna get a notification or YouTube has
an option where they can get a
notification via email so I subscribe to
simply learns Channel I subscribe to
other channels like google analytics for
example so anytime Google Analytics
publishes a video I get an email that
says hey google analytics YouTube
channel just publish the video and the
great thing is I'm checking my email and
I'm getting this notification in Gmail
so guess what I can watch the video
right then and there just by clicking on
the link in the email I don't even have
to go to the channel but knowing that if
you publish consistently and somebody
does get the email once a week then it's
more likely they're going to engage
especially if the content
is original engaging and informative so
frequent video publishing equals more
subscriptions so according to social
media examiner YouTube channels that
publish videos more than once a week are
performing much better so if you can
afford to publish more videos more than
once a week the chances of you gaining
subscribers quicker are gonna be greater
so keeping a fixed frequency can help
you quickly gain more subscribers
posting videos is like almost like
blogging I always say start small if you
could do one blog post a month and then
once you get in a routine then you can
ramp up the frequency so from one blog
post you can do two a month then four
times a month in once a week or twice a
week same with the YouTube videos you
want to get into a rhythm you know start
with once a month then ramp it up okay
though you'll find that the more you
ramp it up the more subscribers you're
gonna get so tip 3 optimize your YouTube
videos so optimizing your videos will
help your content rank higher on YouTube
so this is a gift must it's not a given
it's a must you must optimize your
videos if you want people to see them of
course if you don't optimize people
aren't gonna see them then people aren't
going to engage and then not subscribe
so it's just kind of a snowball effect
so this is an important tip so I mention
it at the beginning when we were going
over all the items were gonna discuss
this is the one item that is a must and
a given to some degree because if you
don't optimize your videos are just not
gonna be found so you need that audience
to watch your video so audiences who
tend to interact more with your content
have more chance to subscribe to your
channel but they're not going to
subscribe if they don't even watch your
video so there is a snowball effect in
play here if we don't optimize your
videos so okay Rob what are some of the
tips to optimize your YouTube video well
let's go through some of those tips so
to ensure your videos reaches the
relevant audience on YouTube you need to
optimize the title description in the
video tag okay Rob what do you mean by
title description and video tag so let's
take a look at that so when you actually
create your YouTube video you
an opportunity to put in a title you're
gonna have an opportunity to put in a
description and you're gonna have an
opportunity to add text so those are the
three key areas okay so once you put in
that what it looks like on the front end
is this so if I go back to YouTube and
here you can see another video that we
did about a month ago you can see what
is SEO so if that's our topic that's our
title or of the content on the video
then the title of the video is going to
be what is SEO and you can see we also
added in some other content for the
title so what is SEO and how does it
work
SEO tutorial for beginners and then our
brand name so we have some content to
work with for the title okay and then
the description we have a lot of
characters to work with description so
use as much as you can here to describe
what the video is about here you can see
we did that and so it's always good to
include this information okay and then
you can see we have tags up here SEO SEO
tutorial for beginners digital marketing
so we put in the necessary information
here on this video to help us rank
because if we don't optimize it we're
not going to rank and so you can see we
just put a lot of relevant content
around the description around the title
and around those tags by doing so we're
able to optimize this video and get
found so that's just an example three of
the things you can do to help optimize
your YouTube video so if you want to
watch more on how to optimize meta tags
then I suggest maybe watching the other
video we did on the subject how to rank
YouTube videos so this goes into more
detail about how to optimize the title
the meta description and the meta tags
but there was a three quick fields or
areas that you can use to optimize your
video so just something to keep in mind
right a long description with keywords
timestamps and links so when I mean by
time stands for timestamp an audience
can choose the section of the video that
they want to look for and then links
prefer to include relevant links of your
other videos so those are just some
additional tips to help keep your
content engage
so remember when your content is
engaging then people are gonna like it
people are gonna share it and watch it
later so uploading captivating thumbnail
okay so you want to include a thumbnail
that's gonna grab people's attention you
want to upload a transcript to the video
so that goes back to when you're
creating your content when you write
your original content you want to keep a
transcript of the content of the video
so that you can upload that as well and
then add a start screen and end screen
to your YouTube videos so that way you
know it's somebody plays the video
they're gonna see it what it looks like
up front and then then we finish it
they're gonna see an end screen at the
end and so you just don't want to keep
it dark and black and non descriptive so
according to backlinko using an exact
keyword and your video title can help
you with rankings so high ranking more
views more views more subscribers so
that's why they've been saying all along
you need to get these videos optimized
so again use an exact keyword in your
video title so let's go back again to
that video I just showed you a couple of
minutes ago what is SEO so here we
started out with a question what is SEO
that's the name of the title that's one
exact title of the video
that's our exact keyword okay so what is
SEO and how does it work and then SEO
tutorial beginners so what is SEO is our
exact keyword and that's part of the
video that's the content of the video
that's in the title and we use it
throughout the description as well so
using that exact keyword in your video
title can help with the rankings so
whatever your topic is your title of the
video or the topic of the video included
in the title so backlinko also mentions
that there is a moderate correlation
between a channels total subscribers and
rankings and so for some of you this may
be common sense it's just like organic
search if you're not ranking you're not
gonna get traffic on YouTube if you're
not ranking you're not gonna get
eyeballs on your videos and you're not
gonna get subscribers so higher rankings
can help you to get more subscribers but
you can't get those rankings unless you
optimize and so again just for the sake
of simplicity going back focus in on
your title make sure your title matches
the title of the video itself when
you're publishing your descript
use all the amount of content available
to you so you can see it this entire
description has a lot of content
maximize the content and then use tags
using those three fields there's three
areas can help you optimize your video
and gain the necessary ranking you need
to get viewers what you'll turn into
subscribers so tip 4 optimize your
YouTube channel so we just talked about
optimizing our videos now we're going to
turn our attention to our YouTube
channel so one of the easiest ways to
ask your views to subscribe to your
channel is really by creating a good not
even a good a great YouTube channel
trailer you also want to add channel
keywords a description and some good
artwork and then having sections and
playlists to keep your videos organized
these are all good tips to creating a
good YouTube channel so let's talk about
some of these these tips here so we want
to give your audience a preview what
your channel is offering so this is by
hooking your audience with the trailer
so you can create a trailer to you know
just give your audience an idea of who
you are as a brand what kind of videos
you're gonna be posting and give them a
kind of a taste of what the future
videos are gonna be like okay you can
even tell them your release schedule in
the trailer so you can start off with
saying hey hey guys we're new to this
we're gonna be posting one video a month
but as we get rolling maybe two per
month and you know one per week you know
just being honest and open and talking
into your audience get them excited
about future videos that's what the
trailer is all about so you also want to
keep it that the channel description
short interesting so in your channel you
want to have a description of what the
channel is all about what kind of videos
you're gonna be posting so in addition
to the trailer you want to write
something short and interesting then we
want to use keywords in our channel
descriptions just like in the videos
with what is SEO we included what is SEO
in the title we included you know what
is SEO in the description and so we want
to be true to what our channel is so
pick keywords not only clue those
keywords in the videos but
include them in the channel description
pay attention to the first 100 to 150
characters I have your channel
description because that's what's shown
next your channel on the search results
so for example here you can see we have
a description here simply learn is one
of the world's leading certification
training providers we partner with
companies and individuals to address and
so you can see those characters hundred
one hundred and fifty or what shows in
the channel description when somebody's
trying to understand hey simply learn
just uploaded this video who is simply
varmint so you want to write short
interesting channel description so that
when somebody's first introduced to your
video they could see what your brand is
all about so in your description with an
appropriate call-to-action so short and
interesting good call to action at the
end of the video a good call to action
would be hey check out our next video or
check out our latest video something
that's going to gauge somebody and get
them to watch one of your videos so you
want to pick interesting channel art so
let's turn our attention of the simply
learn channel page and here you can see
we recently had reached a milestone so
recently reached the two hundred
thousand case absque Rai burs so two
hundred thousand subscribers is a big
achievement for simply learn we went
ahead and updated our channel art and
I'm sure we will reach 500 k will update
the artwork then too but the point is
you want to keep your channel art kind
of interesting hip and cool and feel
free to change it out every once in a
while
so you have that option and YouTube to
do I mean so it's very simple so here
you can see simply learnt Channel we go
home we got all our videos listed here
we got the about us you know something
very short interesting about us here's
our call to action for more information
visit simply learn so you want to make
sure when you create your channel get
some good artwork in there put your
description and play and create your
first videos and get them posted up
there and optimize them accordingly okay
so some other tips to go with that
channel art in description is a profile
picture relevant to your brand so you
always want to maybe put out the the
company logo up there
so here you can see we have the company
logo at accurate relevant channel
keywords so if we go back to who we are
who are we
we're the world's leading certification
training provider okay that's who we are
okay we partner with companies and
individuals so we're all about training
and training is one of our keywords so
you can see that simply learn we provide
online training to machine learning AWS
Amazon Web Services DevOps Big Data
digital marketing project management a
lot of different topics so make sure
that's included in the channel
description feature the playlist on your
home page so if we go back to the home
page we can see here we have our
channels so you can see we have a I
machine learning trending technologies
cloud computing tutorials DevOps
tutorials popular videos big data we
have a lot of different channels so you
want to organize your videos into
different playlists so those playlists
are going to feature on the homepage of
your channel so how you organize the
playlist is totally up to you but I
would certainly create a playlist for
different sections so depending on your
product your services think about how
you want to organize don't just stick
all your videos in one playlist then
optimize the playlists titles and
descriptions for search rankings so just
like the videos themselves just like the
channel description you have an
opportunity to optimize the playlist
titles and description so be very keen
on aligning the right keyword with the
playlist title so here you can see
programming language tutorials project
management tutorials digital marketing
tutorials so we're very clear on how we
go about choosing our titles because we
want to optimize those playlist titles
okay we can rearrange our videos any
playlists so we want to rearrange the
videos in a way that or maybe putting
them freshest the most newest the video
that's been published last first so
almost in descending order if you will
so we want our users to see what video
has the
in that particular playlist so they're
seeing the most recent first but you can
rearrange your videos any way you want
feel free to play around with it of
course you can also take the video
that's the most popular and put that up
front so people could see that first
vice versa you could take a video that
maybe hasn't gotten a lot of views or
isn't ranked particularly high maybe put
that video up so you can get some views
and some shares and likes so how you
rearranged your videos is totally up to
you just have some rationale behind that
so choose a playlist thumbnail from a
top performing video so for example if I
go back to our YouTube page you'd see
the top performing videos here
you know for example this one we got a
nice thumbnail here what is machine
learning so if I click on that I see
most popular videos so three thousand
likes on this video a lot of views 250
thousand plus views so have a thumbnail
to go along with that particular video
so according to backlinko youtube SEO
ranking factors study discovered that
channel keywords have a small yet
significant correlation with higher
youtube search rankings so channel
keywords so when you're optimizing your
channel and you want to include keywords
start with your description so if I go
back to our channel if I go back about
us make sure your description has those
relevant keywords in it that's where it
all starts so in case you have any
doubts if you're not sure about
everything we talked about optimizing
the channel go ahead and drop a comment
below because we do respond to every
comment that gets posted on our videos
so if you're not sure how to go about
optimizing your channel when you say
aligned keywords with the channel what
does that really mean so if you want
some clarity on that go ahead and drop
us a channel if you're not sure about
the trailer video drop us a comment
we're more than happy to expand upon the
explanation of how to best optimize your
channel okay tip number five produce
high quality videos so we need to get in
the
producing high-quality videos because
viewers don't prefer to watch videos
that have poor audio and video quality
it's just that simple you need to know
what it takes to produce high-quality
videos if you don't you're just gonna
discredit you're not gonna come across
as relevant you know I'm gonna come
across as qualified professional there's
a lot of things attached to poor quality
videos so we need to create high quality
videos for the end user so let's talk
about some ways in which you can create
high quality videos and so the first is
to avoid any noise in the background so
you want to have a nice quiet atmosphere
no distractions
so people can hear you clearly and only
you clearly you want to use good audio
recording equipment there's plenty of
options available on the Internet
usually I would recommend going with
something paid not overly expensive
because you get what you pay for so if
you use something free it might not be
of good quality and you might not have
all the features and bells and whistles
with a free option so you know use good
audio recording equipment again it could
be online or it could be some software
just make sure that you're able to
produce good high-quality video and
audio so when you do purchase that audio
recording equipment you want to have
something similar to an input volume
meter that way you can see whether your
audio is coming across or not so if
you're not seeing green lights then your
audio is not coming across if it's red
it might be distorted and so you want
something that's gonna signify that
you're really pushing out good quality
audio you want to create your videos and
1080 pixels size okay that's HD and so
you want to have at least minimum 1080
so anything less than that it's probably
gonna come across as not so good
maybe staticky blurry not professional
not high def so you want to create a
high def video and 1080 is about the
minimum you want to go and then you want
to plan your video script before filming
so goes back to some of the other points
I made earlier you always want to have a
video script available so you know what
you're saying
when
you're recording your audio that way
you're not doing something on the fly
then you want to use good lighting for
video recording so you don't want to be
in a dark place you want to some nice
lighting so your video comes across well
lit people could see you they're not
struggling to strain their eyes on what
it is you're trying to show and appear
because of poor lighting again it just
comes across as professional so if you
can you know shoot a high-def video with
good audio speaking clearly having a
professional script with some good
lighting the people are going to take
you serious and they're going to start
to listen and engage and see the video
is good quality and very relevant and
informative and share it so you slow
motion and jump cuts wisely so there's
some features you could do with your
video you know using slow motion and
jump cuts are some of the features you
can use to accentuate your points then
set up a green background for recording
again this is for you know making sure
that the video part of it comes across
and good quality and stabilize your
video recordings with the tripod that
way you're not moving your video camera
all around and and again it's coming
across the shaky and poor quality shoot
horizontal videos you don't want to go
vertical it tends to cut the screen so
you want to stay horizontal so that
people can see everything that should be
included in the video okay you want to
capture a wider shot using a clip-on
lens again a good feature a good tip to
use use that wider shot okay so you
could do that using a clip-on lens and
then choose good video editing software
I can't state this enough because you're
putting all this time and effort into a
video you need to be able to edit it to
cut out you know some of the things you
didn't want to say or maybe some poor
quality or or you know you just want to
have a smooth professional output for
your video and so you gotta have good
video editing software there's plenty of
options available on the internet again
I would go with something low cost but
paid usually free isn't exactly the way
you want to go if you're trying to
create a high-def good quality video the
very least review your work before
publishing I just said it a minute ago
I'll say it
you want to be able to have a really
professional video and high def when you
have a good professional video in high
def with good audio horizontal shots you
know a nice green background image nice
well lit it's gonna come across as
professional and if you have a
professional video then people are gonna
take you seriously they're gonna see you
as a professional and then share or
subscribe and like and then they're
gonna watch more videos and and that's
how you start to build up a reputation
as being a very professional
organization so just following these
simple tips on producing high quality
videos so you want to review your work
because if you don't you put all that
effort into it and then you're gonna
realize hey your video is low-quality
and then you're gonna have to do it all
over again so follow these tips get a
high quality video and you should be on
your way to ranking in fact according to
backlink go you to preferably ranks HD
videos so you got to have that 1080
pixel size that way you know your video
is gonna come across crisp and clear and
YouTube prefers that tip 6 I had a
subscriber watermark to your videos so
this is a great feature in YouTube so
it's a feature that allows you to add a
watermark that can be shown on all your
videos the reason why you want that
watermark because you want to keep
reminding your audience to subscribe to
your channel
the watermark can be whatever you want
but normally it's gonna be some type of
logo or brand in a call to action and so
how do you add a watermark to your video
well you log in to your YouTube account
it's pretty simple at the top right
corner you're gonna select your creator
studio icon and then you're gonna go to
channel select branding and then add a
watermark to your video so if we look at
that on YouTube so here creator studio
on the left side navigation I'm just
gonna click channel then I'm gonna click
branding and then once you click
branding you have the ability to add
your watermark and then you can add it
to the entire video at the end of the
video a specific start time and then
click update and that's pretty much it
so you want to be able to add this
you can brant your videos with an image
and then add that CTA so this is a good
good feature for YouTube it allows you
to be consistent with all your videos by
branding and adding that call-to-action
tip 7 engage with your audience so you
want to be able to interact with your
audience as much as possible just
because the video and you can't see
people doesn't mean you can engage with
them so when you interact with your
viewers especially when you interact
with them immediately
there's gratification you know everybody
likes to be responded to nobody likes to
be ignored and so when somebody is
responded to there's a higher chance
that your viewers are likely to gonna
become customers it's just customer
services is how you really want to look
at this okay so when you engage you're
creating a service for your customers so
here are some tips on how to engage with
your audience so first is at the end of
every video convey a thank you message
to your viewers you know thank you for
spending the time out of your busy day
to watch this video you know some of our
videos go an hour-plus long and so when
somebody's taking an hour to watch a
video it's only the least you can do is
thank them now you can thank them and
give them some information about where
to go for more information
because if they watch the whole video
they're already engaged and they're
probably gonna want to learn more so you
always want to follow up - thank you
with where to go for more information
just like our videos always convey at
the end okay you always want to ask your
audience for their feedback or ideas on
the video so with YouTube there's a
comment section and you always want to
encourage comments so comments can be in
the form of feedback so as you're
watching this video feel free to leave
feedback on other ways to engage with
your audience or some other tips to
increase your subscribers on YouTube so
we're always looking for those ideas we
want to keep it engaging so somebody may
have some other ideas that we didn't
think about and so we always appreciate
that from our audience so we very much
appreciate the feedback that our
audience gives us so not all the
feedback there's always going to be
positive some of the feedback could be
less than positive or even negative
could be mistakes so the idea behind
getting feedback as you want to look at
it you want to read it and you want to
react to it you want to react to it
positively in the form of you know what
thank you for the feedback and looking
at the feedback weighing it and
incorporating the feedback so you don't
always want to make the same mistake
twice in a video so if there's something
definitely wrong with the video that
we're doing for example and somebody
looked at it and gave us feedback on it
we'd certainly definitely take a deep
look into that and try not to do the
same mistake twice
because likely that user is going to
watch the video again so you always want
to learn from your mistakes and you want
to turn those mistakes or turn those
comments into future videos maybe so
create videos based on your commoners
request the audience is giving us
feedback we should take that as positive
and sometimes that's creative sometimes
those ideas for more videos okay you
always want to ask questions to your
audience and reward excellent commenters
so we try to ask questions and our
videos and when users respond with the
answer if there's an excellent comment
or excellent answer you know we can
reward them you know reward them in the
form of say some type of gift card or
gift certificate or promotion or
something there's always some way to
incentivize somebody who provides
excellent feedback can always give emoji
hearts there's so many emojis out there
that you can use emojis just to engage
with your audience based on the feedback
that they're giving the point is if your
audience is taking the time to give
feedback you always want to respond to
it and you want to respond to a positive
so emojis tend to have a positive
connotation to them and so responding
with an emoji especially to a favorite
comment goes a long way so you can
reward your community both on and off
YouTube for their engagement and support
and that's just being creative you can
reward and many
in many ways not necessarily monetarily
but by recognition you could do
promotions you could do something fun
there's always ways to reward and prefer
to host live streams and interact with
your audience so you don't always have
to do a pre-recorded video
there's certainly YouTube has other
platforms like Facebook have them
Instagram so you can certainly reach out
to your audience with a live stream and
that's talking directly to your audience
right there in the flesh so when you can
have an opportunity to talk to your
audience and engage with them that's
always gonna work because they can see
personality they can see what you're all
about and there's two-way conversation
and so that will lend to more of a you
know relationship so to speak with your
audience so you want to create videos
for subscribers and subscribers can get
impressed when a channel dedicates a
video for them so you know take the time
out to create a video just for your
subscribers subscribers are the ones who
are most likely going to engage with you
ok they're your loyal fanbase
so if you create something for them
that's a form of a reward so you can
captivate your viewers by uploading
interesting YouTube stories as well you
can also hear from your audience and get
their videos and use their videos and
upload them to your channel so according
to backlinko video comments of a very
strong correlation with rankings so as
you create a video feel free to talk to
your audience and ask them hey you have
any comments feel free to put them in
the comment section right below this
video I see that a lot now with a lot of
videos and I'm gonna ask my audience
right now to do the same thing if
there's anything you see about rewarding
the audience or engaging with the
audience feel free to comment we'd love
to get your suggestions because if you
can engage with the audience even more
then that's only going to net positive
results not only in rankings but with
your subscriber base so comments are the
way to go
solicit comments respond to the comments
reward the comments tip number 8 promote
your videos on different platforms so
promoting your videos on different
platforms has been around for many years
it's a good strategy once you create
your video on YouTube you want people to
see it you want to get it out there so
if you want to increase your you
describers this is a strategy you have
to perform so let's take a look at all
the ways you can use and leverage
different platforms to increase your
subscribers so before you do that you
want to research discover how you can
use different platforms so the first
thing you want to do is look at the
platforms you're already using you're
using Facebook and Instagram that's
probably a good place to start but
there's other platforms you can also
leverage we're going to talk about those
so social media most companies most
individuals are on in some form or
fashion amongst the most popular like
Facebook and Instagram so you could
start there so with Facebook you can
post something and include the link of
your YouTube video with Facebook if
you're a business you have a business
page you're communicating with your
community and that's a great way to get
started by promoting your YouTube video
you can also do the same on Twitter or
Instagram or whatever platform you're on
go ahead and post something or tweet
something and include that link to
YouTube you can participate in forums
and blog discussions so there's plenty
of forums and blogs out there where you
can participate in a discussion and
include a link to the YouTube video if
it's relevant and natural so for example
here there's a blog about machine
learning you can include if you have a
video about machine learning in the
response to that conversation in this
example we've done that on reddit you
can list your video and relevant and
reputable directories there's plenty of
directories out there there's plenty of
video directories okay that you can just
go ahead and publish your video on you
can use testimonial link building okay
so somebody can provide a testimony and
include the link of your video you can
opt for influence or marketing so if
there's somebody that is associated that
likes your brand or product and has a
large following you can ask them to post
a video on your behalf it's a great way
to reach an audience fairly quickly okay
you can earn backlinks from relative
relevant and authoritative websites so
for example if you look at this website
here touch genex okay there's a article
here about you know certificate of
achieve
okay for AWS so if you scroll down we
could see our video is included here in
this particular webpage so this is a
high quality web page okay that's
generating a backlink for us not only is
it generating a backlink it's also
generating traffic and awareness for the
video go ahead and find out if there's
any websites that are relevant to your
video topic and see if you can
collaborate with them on producing a
webpage to include that video you can
also take advantage of email marketing
by adding your youtube link in the email
signature for example it's a simple
email any email client like Gmail or
Yahoo or even hotmail or Outlook it's
going to have an ability to or give you
the ability to add a signature in the
signature you could simply just include
a link to the video or to your YouTube
channel it doesn't have to be do a
specific video but it's a way to get
people to your YouTube page or to that
video so the whole idea is more eyeballs
more potential subscribers engage your
audience by posting your video links on
community pages so for example you know
we're promoting something here on a
community page and that's gonna get some
additional traffic over to us you can
always bookmark your videos I'm
bookmarking sites like stumbled upon com
again this is free very little time to
do this but it's a chance for you to get
the video out there and even generate a
backlink you can collaborate with other
YouTube channels this is always a good
strategy if you're creating a video on a
particular topic on YouTube chances are
there's probably somebody else out there
doing the same thing it doesn't have to
be necessarily competitor it can be a
complimentary product or service and if
you offer that then go ahead and
collaborate with them and see if you can
exchange your videos on their channel
and you could take their video and put
it on your channel in a particular
playlist okay so that's a way to
collaborate with other YouTube channels
is swap videos you could join high PR QA
sites and post answers to the questions
related to your video like core is
always a good example or II happen so
core there's always a question to be
imposed
if you have the answer to that question
in the form of your video then go ahead
and post a response with a link to the
video on YouTube it's a great way to get
the video notice and it's relevant and
natural okay you're going to bed videos
in your blog post so if you use it a
platform like WordPress for example very
easy to go ahead and just take that
video you can even just put the link in
the blog post I like this option I think
blog posts are always good because you
don't have to be text-heavy with a blog
post you want to create a blog post
that's nice and balanced with an image
and text but if you put a video to
support your blog post that goes even
further and blog posts themselves can be
engaging and interactive with your
audience so having a video and your blog
post always goes well in my opinion okay
so you could promote other videos in
your end screen for example at the end
of your video you can always promote
something related like we've done here
in this example so lots of ideas get
your video out there use him an email
use him in your blog post go to free
bookmarking sites like stumble upon you
know collaborate with other people on
YouTube you know go to Corps respond to
a question use social media to your
advantage there's lots of opportunities
to get your video out there the more you
can get your video out there the more
traffic you're gonna get the more
traffic you get to the video the more
subscribers you're going to get so
that's how the game is played in order
to get your video out there but these
are relatively you know low
time-consuming ideas to get your video
some some subscribers so let's turn our
attention some key takeaways from
today's video tip one you always want to
create engaging and informative content
so that's where it all starts remember
think about what you want to say and do
before you do it know your audience
that's really the key takeaway know your
audience
tip 2 publish videos frequently okay you
don't have to start out publishing three
or four a week you know start out
publishing one a month if that's how it
works for you and then once you build
momentum once you start getting a loyal
fanbase and start getting more
subscribers and think about it
senior video output tip 3 optimizer of
youtube videos title description tags
that's always a good place to start
you'll want to work in that keyword
that's relevant to the topic and work
that into the title work it into the
description and work it in to those tags
tip 4 you want to optimize your YouTube
channel there's lots of features
available ok you want to start with your
description of your channel because the
description is what shows up when
somebody does a search or sees your
video so that is key you always want to
optimize your channel as well as your
videos tip 5 we want to produce high
quality videos remember 1080 on the
pixel you know use good audio video
equipment don't necessarily go free go
with something low cost but make sure
you're using something that's going to
output good audio and video quality
because people are gonna take you
serious tip 6 good feature in YouTube
under the channel settings okay in the
creator studio you want to be able to
have a subscriber watermark that way
people know who you are and you can add
that call to action so that to conserve
to your video tip 7 engage with your
audience comments comments comments in
fact for those watching this video now
if you have any comments on any of the
tips that we provided feel free to put
them in there we will respond and we
will reward and that's what you want to
do with your audience you want to engage
with your audience to make them feel
like they're part of the community
and part of the solution and then tip 8
promote your videos and different
platforms there's plenty of
opportunities from social to blog posts
to influence your marketing to email
marketing lots of different
opportunities to get that link out there
the more you can get that link out there
the more traffic you're gonna drive the
more traffic the more eyeballs are gonna
realize hey this is some good stuff here
I'm gonna subscribe to this video I'm
going to subscribe to this channel and
I'm gonna wait for this channel to
produce more videos so these are the
tips and with these key takeaways in
these tips you should be on your way to
increasing your subscriber base so thank
you again if you have any comments about
this video feel free to post them
underneath we will respond and we
you appreciate it and if you have any
questions please feel free to visit
simply learn comm thank you and I'll see
you on future videos
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here